all right well on to another strong
woman my first guest is the voice behind
hits including good for you I love the
song Same Old love I love that one too
and the song I sing during karaoke lose
you to love me such a great album it's a
new album called rare it's out now give
it up for Selena Gomez
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
all right what do you want to hear
you gotta sit down at some point that's
amazing does that happen like in Target
like
you just walk in and you're like well
thank you I arrived at the time they're
like cutting her or that's always
whatever sweats and everything yes but
you went to your childhood home is that
kind of special for you like yeah it was
so well I I try to go there um often
just because it's
um it's nostalgic for me and I've gone
every year so uh well there's me and uh
but I grew up there everything started
from there so I actually got to knock on
the door and someone was finally there
because no one's ever there you know is
this just chill dude and he's like yeah
come look around he was so unfazed that
I was there he's like yeah apparently
you wrote on this wall it goes also
there's a crib in the garage if you
wanted I was like my crib he was like
yeah I was like my crib is in your
garage she goes man I was like can I
have it you're sure
and I had written in the closets that I
was in love with uh Cole Sprouse
older than you who is that
Cole Sprouse
um was on Suite Life of Zack and Cody
okay obsessed with that show and I
thought we were going to be together one
day
then I guess start on the show but I
kissed his brother and I didn't get to
kiss
[Music]
for y'all I hate acting so like I I
don't know how you
how you have been oh my gosh your first
kiss was with a stranger and an actor
it was one of the worst days of night
you know what mine wasn't acting and it
was on camera mine was horrible it was
like he was searching for something with
his tongue it was yeah it was I was like
there's nothing in there it's just my
mouth like and then I literally went and
spit in his bathroom it was horrible but
I don't I don't think I to the last time
to ask you this last time you were here
but how did you and your husband meet
because I know Matt is an incredible
writer he literally wrote one of my
favorite songs I've ever recorded
someone like he's so talented so how did
y'all meet was it while you're working
like yeah well yes so we got set up we
are both at RCA and we got set up
um by our a r person there just not not
set up like that but just set up to work
yeah and I was like cutting a couple of
the songs that he had had written and we
met at Aroma Cafe on Tujunga in the
valley and we ended up being there for
like two hours talking and I was like
I gotta go what am I doing why are we
talking about all these like 90s music
that we like and like really connecting
because you're cool and 90s music is
awesome yeah yeah so that so that's how
we met and then we recorded a little bit
in the studio and everything was pretty
professional and then he asked me out on
a date it was around Valentine's Day and
then we like casually kind of started
dating like a month after that and we
broke up and then we got back together
and then we broke up and then we got
back together I was like we should have
a baby and then we had a baby and I was
like any of my kids you're all gonna die
really great for us oh my God oh my gosh
I love this story this is a movie yeah
and like two weeks later I'm pregnant oh
my God I know he is funny I have to show
you this he replaced their faces in the
house to see if you would notice I guess
yeah with the Jonas brothers did you
know on like our frame photos Okay well
here's what I did notice we get People
magazine in the mail and so I saw the
magazine and it was like shredded
sitting on the on the counter and it was
a Jonas Brothers one I'm like I don't
even know what to think about my my kids
probably did something weird with this
magazine yeah right and so then you guys
that's my birthing photo okay that's so
burning yeah and so then he had cut all
the Jonas Brothers heads out and put
them on all of our frame photos in the
house he's so weird if weird means
awesome I just it I love that it's just
so fun he waited until I noticed and it
took like a couple of days for me to
which says something
maybe not so observant in your household
well there's just a million three kids
and a lot of animals I get it no no I
get it he's he's a really great
prankster and honestly some of the posts
on Instagram if you don't follow him on
Instagram it's quite a laugh sometimes
this stuff is so weird it goes over my
head I'm like I didn't get that one and
then the other ones I'm like I'm dead
you're so funny yeah he is it just you
know it seem like you have such a cute
relationship like friendship as well
totally we do we do and um you know he's
a real chatty guy so yeah at the end of
the day when I come home from work and
I'm like tapped he like downloads all
the information to me from the day and
we kind of like he gives me all current
events and his hot takes on every yeah
he's he's just great but I left a note I
went to New York last week and I left a
note for my kids because I left I left
at like 4am and I'm like love you family
I'll miss you guys and he just posts on
Instagram a picture of and he's like I
think my wife left me
it's been 16 years since High School
Musical do you remember the beginning of
that because that was your big first
thing yeah like I remember all the
auditions definitely because there were
a lot of them oh really uh-huh oh yeah I
mean there were like three but like I I
you know the same thing with Idol people
don't know that but there were there
were many auditions before you got to
the TV part oh yeah of course I like
remember meeting Zach for the first time
meeting Lucas for the first time me and
Ashley had already met
um because we did a commercial together
like a month prior yeah yeah um but it's
it's wild the time just keeps flying
yeah well you start so young that's I
think that's what happens yeah I'm like
I got decades under my belt now I know
it feels weird I feel weird saying like
20 years and that feels weird yeah but
do you ever hear from like younger kids
just now discovering it because my
speaking of my daughter my kids actually
were introduced to my nanny is in love
with you as well so she showed them a
High School Musical and they love it so
do you have like little kids now coming
back because you're like that was a long
time ago I mean they're just now some
time ago I know what they think is it
weird do they think because my daughter
like she'll see people and she'll be
like wait but is that the same girl
because they don't get that it came out
like years ago totally do you get kids I
mean I feel like I kind of look the same
congratulations on that that doesn't
jeans
yeah but yeah like we're so crazy
because it continues to live on like for
generations and but like that's
streaming that's like the magic of
musicals though you know like I I
remember watching West Side Story for
the first time when I was like three
years old and like now there's a new one
for the new generation like musicals
just have this like Legacy about them
they they don't go out of style I think
also it has a lot to do I mean the story
yes but also the music is what
captivates you and I know you put out
albums like while you were doing that so
are you gonna do that again I like I
like you singing thank you I like
singing too they like me singing
um I I
it definitely I had to sit back for a
second and like figure out what it is
that I wanted to do because like yeah
I'm like I I felt like if I was going to
do it again I wanted it to be like
really authentically myself and like
really be my own voice and perspective
and and writing and I just like honestly
haven't gotten there it hasn't been like
the main priority I feel like if I was
to do anything like a jazz something
would probably be the first that's cool
yeah I love when people do this me too
but I love when people do like
unexpected like that too yeah I mean
it's just personal like that's what I
listen to like I've always got Julie
London or Billie Holiday playing at my
house and people are like interesting
I'm like I'm a grandma I don't know yeah
I have some Grandma taste about me too
but I think it's just called Good Taste
yes it is yeah I think it's just like
classic sound that sounds good yeah well
to combine their love
their upcoming residency it is time for
a clever game it's cleverly named called
what's popping in Vegas
you better sing Jessie we need a host oh
Lord are you there I am here how you
doing Kelly I'm great all right Hey
Kevin Nick Joe how you boys doing I'll
tell you what I don't care what anyone
says y'all my favorite creation that's
what I'm talking about
thank you okay now here's how this game
works I'm gonna ask a question that has
to do with Las Vegas in some way or
another and if you know the answer
you're gonna hit your button and let me
have it now you can hit the button
before I'm done talking but why deprive
yourself of my golden voice okay now
also the Commandments don't
because Steels are allowed okay now
here's your first question oh okay
according to experts what game in Las
Vegas has the best odds for you winning
what Baccarat
it is I'm sorry you can steal Now kill
it come on
oh there we go
um I'm gonna go I don't know I don't
know I'm gonna go with uh Blackjack it
is
[Applause]
here's your next question okay now this
one is for both teams no buzzing in on
this one okay whoever can guess closer
without going over this number will get
Five Points okay I'm gonna ask Nick I'm
gonna ask Nick and Kevin first to guess
here's the question explain it
approximately how many weddings a day
happen in Las Vegas
oh my gosh
it's too high sure 30. do we answer now
you can answer now yes you may 37 37
okay that's your guess all right now
Kelly and Joe approximately how many
weddings a day happened in Las Vegas do
you think
Bob
seventy-five okay well Kelly and Joe you
win because the correct answer is 300.
it is actually 300.
[Applause]
I was 220 Nick's like there's no way
the next one's worth 20. so okay fine
the next one is worth 20. you set it and
I'll make it so
here is
here is the question okay worth 20
points
where in Las Vegas are the Jonas
Brothers playing from June 3rd till the
11th please don't mess this up Kev you
can do it take it away
Park MGM theater it is the park MGM
theater
[Applause]
[Music]
that's how it goes well wait in that
clip we
don't have you seen we've ever had an
experience I have never seen
an E.T face to face but I have seen a
lot of weird things in the sky that
can't be explained and even on the
ground nope yes so
I did hypnotherapy and I've always
wanted to do it for like separate
reasons but like you you did
hypnotherapy to learn more about the
encounter right yes did you have a crazy
experience doing it I didn't have like a
crazy experience doing it but I think
doing it for this I did it for a crazy
experience that I had I had a night
where I was dreaming and I say dreaming
very Loosely because I don't really know
what happened but I all of a sudden was
in my room and and I know I said I so I
I I sound
but this is going to sounds so out there
but just bear with me so I woke up in my
room and there was like three beings and
then and they they were oh do you want
to see your planet and I was like oh
sorry you were like hell I was like hell
yeah let's go so so I like whooshed out
of my room and was like hovering over
the planet and then all of a sudden
they're like you want to see our planet
and I was like hell yeah yeah then I
wish to this like pink and purple planet
that I've never seen But and then and so
that with the hypnotherapy I was like
trying to figure out what exactly that
was was it like I don't want to use the
word abduction because that implies that
it wasn't with consent I was totally for
it you know what I said hell yeah
abduction I called it an astral
projection for a long time because I
went somewhere else but then I realized
maybe this was just an encounter that I
had yeah and I talk about that on the
show it well it's so funny that you're
talking about this like because it's
stuff like that real or is it you're
just like so vulnerable and your walls
are down and you're so like that I sound
like a stoner
I'm not I'm not a donor
I'm not I'm I'm not a stoner I just I
just mean like it was interesting
watching this show because I was like
wait so maybe it's like it really
doesn't allow you because this one
character ends up actually letting their
walls down and like and and you're like
well maybe that's what they really are
feeling and they just weren't able to
feel that and it's really real so I
don't know I'm not against all of it
being real yeah I'm just terrified of it
being real I think I think a common
misunderstanding that that these beings
are bad because of all the movies that
we've seen oh yeah like Independence Day
or yeah like it's like we do with sharks
yeah you make them horrible they're just
yeah yes but I think they've been here
longer I think that they've been here
longer and I think that oh you're
talking about sharks yeah I'm talking
you're totally right they've been here
longer I feel like am I stoned
no I am not
um but but I think that they're just
looking out for the well-being of
humanity like I think that they're well
I'll take that yeah I think we need all
the help we can get we do amen but I'll
tell you what Old Town Road was a song
that just it became the people's song
and the people embraced the song around
the world and they made it you know they
took the walls down there was no walls
there was no barrier so I'm a big fan of
Johnny Cash you know Johnny Cash it's
always about music being inclusive yeah
not divisive and this song was something
the whole world could sing the whole
world could dance and that's what I love
about the collaboration too because I'm
going to be real with you I really need
to know how that collaboration happened
like did Lil Nas exercise call you or
were you just at a dinner or like what
it's not a very exciting story I was
having coffee with Tish we just woke up
and um
she was going through her business thing
and reading emails and stuff and she
said oh
Columbia Records just reached down to
see if you'd like to sing with little
Nas X on this song called Old Town Road
and naturally I say well
who's little nazex and then I go well
we're not here I never heard the song
she said Tick Tock and I said what's
tick tock
and so she dialed in the video and all
of a sudden it just started playing and
I immediately I just stood up I go
that's me I want in on this and oh
that's so cool that it happened well no
I stood up I said that's me and it had
happened one other time in my life when
I heard the demo of achy breaky heart I
stood up and I said that's me I want on
that and um that's exciting you know
what I think it always works with
especially artists and whatever your art
is if you love it it works I think you
know what I'm saying if you're all in
because even if it's not super
successful you loved it and you got to
do what you love and there's no lose
there I I loved it and I loved little
gnaws the more I read about him the more
I studied his life and kind of what he
was going through at that moment and the
fact that there seemed to be some type
of resistance toward it in country music
and that he was reaching out to me as
they called it they they need a country
element and little gnaws for some reason
like why do you think he picked you
because he picked you he asked you he
did yeah and um they tell me well
actually he told me too that it was
because he watched Hannah Montana
[Laughter]
thank you I love that I know I'm so
thankful I did that show I know I'm just
well not sex everyone he's so like
awesome extrovert and I just see him
sitting at home just watching something
but you have a role when working
together what is it
oh we each have a CBA which we can pull
at any time during the record hiking
it's a can't be our gift card and it we
stole it from the national it's
basically like you can't be argued oh
can't be argued you could do this on set
too yeah
or we use it the other way opposite of a
veto where it's like this is my can't be
argued this is my thing that if you take
this away from me this is gonna not work
for the band like I need this moment let
me get one you get one get one oh you
only get one that's good we each get one
because her album per day
[Laughter]
has there ever been one where the the
other has been like
no really I don't know the thing this is
a good idea where you you really push
you know you're like come on we're
usually on the same page like when it
comes to Joint decisions like we really
are I don't know why but like if someone
ever put your pardon you'd been like no
you know the only time yes
and then we were like should we tell the
story no but but I do think on this
record there was one song in particular
that stood out to us that I knew was
like this is going on the record yeah
and Ali was like I don't know it's not
like it feels a little bit soft compared
to the other songs it's a little more
gospel leaning but like we also know
that that's kind of where Our Roots came
from so we were like let's honor this
yeah but Ali was like I'm not sure if it
was I don't know guessing it I was like
this is my CBA this song is going on and
thank God and then and now I actually I
mean I it makes sense that it's on the
record and I I'm glad that AJ pulled it
yeah the CBA out yeah usually that's all
artists do that we second guess things
yeah and you can't ever predict like
what people are gonna like anyway so you
might as well just pick what you love
and put it out the Beatles would still
have been together if they had a CV
there you go
oh
yeah
it's a slightly woman thing of of
recognizing someone's and guys I'm sorry
I agree with you um
and if they had this you know maybe some
of the great bands would still be
together that broke up well maybe we'll
change the history right here yeah
now you're welcome you're welcome
everyone gets a CBA today yeah
okay what do I do with this I'm going to
use that with my kids
um so but they're not allowed to have
one
I'm just kidding it's a democracy and I
also know you're very powerful because
you tried to start your own band when
you were a kid but you were too bossy
yeah no I'm
[Laughter]
not I use my parents printer like all of
their ink you know very expensive and I
would print out business cards for a
business I didn't have and I was a
choreographer and then I was looking for
band mates and I put flyers all over and
no one responds no one calls
they should have answered that flyer I
put up a lot of stuff
and uh so yeah I was a one-person band
for a long time and it's interesting
because my my biggest weakness growing
up was that I I was gay and that I was
different from everyone else and now
it's become my biggest strength because
it's empowered me to
I guess why is it because you are who
you are yeah and I I really feared
growing up because I was like life is
going to be so difficult and people are
just not going to understand and going
into my music
um career I was just like why like if
I'm scared everyone else will be so I
have to embrace who I am I have to be
the brave one because if I take that
first step everyone else will follow and
they they will hopefully
grow to
you know feel inspired and know that
they can have a good life they don't
have to commit suicide they don't have
to not love themselves they can be loved
and it's it's it's about all these
incredible powerful women and just
people in general taking that first step
and initiative to Showcase that
absolutely I love you
I love it let me ask you though as a
child star well both of you you seem
incredibly normal you know do you see
this ridiculous outfit I'm wearing okay
besides that but no but you know what I
mean did you at any point did you feel
like oh I want to just be a kid I want
to go back or do you do you seem like
you handle them pretty well that's
really nice I'll let you go first
I'm just grateful that you think that we
look normal
[Laughter]
um no I mean I think uh it was a little
a little easier for me to step into
normality just because I I grew up here
my friends are here I went to college
here I went to high school here I I have
a really nice Community around me
um my my parents are still together
thankfully they love each other very
much they love me and my brother very
much and I kind of grew up in a
community that was just all love and
school was very important so no matter
what I was doing whether it was Hannah
Montana or I was in college through
Young and Hungry it just School kind of
took precedent a lot of the time and
that helped me keep my head on straight
and I've got a like a kind of a
ubiquitous amount of ridiculous Hobbies
so that kind of helped us no but that's
you know that's great
[Music]
good
[Applause]
yeah
guys I'm going
[Music]